foreign
[Music]
firefighters are attacking the Flames
trying to keep them from reaching the
Treetops
despite the long and exhausting Wildfire
season in British Columbia the crews are
persevering you're pushing the limits of
what humans can do in this job a lot of
the time but they're physically
emotionally or intellectually just the
the the amount you have to manage any
given moment BC has had record-breaking
Wildfire Seasons before but this one is
the most destructive more than 2 million
hectares have burned so far on the front
lines is the BC Wildfire service if you
don't have any more eyes on the far side
so if you guys want to walk with me and
we can just go take a quick look we were
granted rare access to experience what
crews are up against we joined them at
the end of July as they wrestled the
Rossmoor Lake Wildfire just south of
Kamloops
looks like the wind's just gonna stay
favorable I spoke to Halco
Aus Al Mubarak is a task force leader
I'm trying to do a surface burn what I
want to do is I want to remove all the
surface fuels because that's how fire
starts to spread if I take that out of
the way out of the equation I can walk
away from here being very confident that
my fire will not wrap around me it's a
tactic that uses fire to fight fire in
this case they're using small hand
torches to burn natural fuels on the
ground like dried grasses
over the course of the next few days
they'll do a number of planned ignitions
all of it carefully considered and
executed so I need to make sure that
this is already black because what is
black doesn't burn again
this Wildfire season is the most serious
fire fight Canada has ever faced over 18
million hectares engulfed Nationwide and
that figure is growing every day more
than 230 000 people had to be evacuated
from their homes and the military has
been deployed this has been
unprecedented but unfortunately it's
what fire scientists and climatologists
have predicted is going to happen
Robert gray is a Wildland fire ecologist
who's been working in the field for more
than four decades he says acceleration
of climate change is amplifying the
length and severity of fire Seasons we
know that as the global mean temperature
rises we're going to see longer fire
Seasons hotter fires bigger fires more
severe fires there was hope that this
wouldn't happen for another decade or so
but it's happening now which means that
we'll likely see worse than this in the
future
Legends excess Forest debris and hot and
dry weather can all be contributing
factors lightning strikes caused nearly
half of all Wildland fires in Canada
according to the federal government and
in BC it's about 60 percent climate
change is resulting in more lightning so
for every one degree C increase in
global mean temperature research shows
there's about a 12 increase in lightning
lightning is a major cause of fires in
British Columbia we get lightning storms
all throughout the summer
we're able to track those storms using
weather radars so we can see that fires
as a result of that three at McConnell
for two pickups Adam Buchanan a member
of the BC Wildfire service and a former
fire investigator it took us to a Barren
landscape littered with charred trees
dried soil and seared holes even though
you can't see it on the surface he
explained how fires can burn underground
to me this looks like an animal burrow
it's not that what are these holes when
the fire moved through here it consumed
the stump and also burnt all the roots
and so the fire will not just consume
everything on top like we can see but it
also moves its way and finds whatever
vegetation is available to burn
underneath and so when we're putting
this out it takes a lot longer because
we can't just spray water on the top we
have to come and check these and and
this could still be burning 10 12 15
feet down any one of these routes that
we're looking at wow so we were deemed
safe to come to this area how did we
know that there wouldn't be a hot spot
the only way to know for sure is to get
in there with our hands feel it see if
it's hot and if it is then spend some
time to make sure we put it out
[Music]
how's the truck looking
firefighters here at Rossmoor will use
the same process to determine if the
Wildfire is out
but they have a long way to go before
getting to that point crews are into
their second week of fighting and there
is no end in sight what's your message
to General Public here now going into
August bear with us we're trying our
best there's usually stages in the
season where there's more fires and The
Limited number of people we have can
handle especially this year the whole
country got strapped at the same time
and so resources we'd have had
traditionally
who just weren't there it's a criticism
we hear again and again there is simply
not enough people power to put out all
the wildfires more than 4 300
international firefighters have been
called in to help I think that's
going to be the game plan at just this
site there are units from Mexico and the
U.S for the first time I've seen the US
be able to come help us when we couldn't
help them so it's good to see them here
I was talking to one guy today and he
was saying he's already done 60 days my
main focus of being here is just you
know how can we help
we are honored to be here it's amazing
as far as we know some of the first
engines and strike teams that can just
drive through the border and come assist
on this and hopefully this is an
agreement that stays
the agreements of having other
firefighters come in and help Canadians
is not new we've been doing it for years
similar Canadians have gone to other
countries to help what is different is
the use and the Reliance on the
municipal firefighters this year has
surpassed anything we've ever seen
before in the past Chief Ken McMullen is
the president of the Canadian
Association of Fire Chiefs he says the
wildfires are so large this year
significantly more local fire
departments have sprung into action
either to fight the Flames approaching
populated areas or help with evacuations
many Municipal firefighters are
volunteers and the length of this season
is taking its toll the volunteer fire
system has been around for centuries and
it works most of the time what it's not
designed to do is for these long
drawn-out events that we're now into
three months going on to it that we have
to make sure that we're doing everything
that we can to ensure they're protected
this summer the federal government
announced funding to train 1 000 new
Wildland firefighters over five years
that won't solve the problem and some
experts say it's time to reevaluate how
fires are managed
Wildland firefighting is mostly a
provincial or territorial responsibility
technically there is a National
Organization that coordinates resources
but its scope is limited and there are
calls for the Canadian government to
create a new National body similar to
the Federal Emergency Management agency
or FEMA in the U.S we believe that
there's some great parallels Canada
could look at and duplicate off of that
so we've asked the federal government to
consider implementing a National Fire
advisor a position that would be
embedded in the government to help
coordinate all disciplines and all
ministries of government when it comes
to significant events similar to what
we've seen this summer there's going to
be values to both the wildland
firefighter system as well as the
municipal firefighting system if we just
get more firefighters we're just putting
more firefighters lives at risk what
we've been suggesting and Advising the
government is we need to build capacity
for sure but that capacity has to be
this holistic approach around fire and
fuels
so far there is no commitment to create
a new federal agency even if there was
it wouldn't happen overnight
those on the fire line are working
tirelessly with new fires erupting all
the time the goal now is to find
solutions to minimize the destruction
and save lives it's been a long summer
and there's moments where
I'm tired and I
just want it to be winter again but I
know there's still a lot of Summer left
we'll just keep putting our head down
until we can take a breath of fresh air
I just want to do a quick touch base
we've had a lot of movement a lot of
transition last couple days it's the
start of another busy day for the crew
on the Rossmoor Lake Wildfire I know
some people are new to the fire but if
you've been on the on the fire you know
that this area that we're in we get a
lot of variable winds things change
really quick so just be aware of that
can I ask what the log book's all about
we have all of our notes as proof of
things that we did Escape Routes where
we're located what we're doing for the
day
see out there on the line for days we've
been on the control line with
firefighters who are trying to make
Headway against the Flames can win
Wildfire officer Jimmy Hague is one of
them I needed that I'm glad he's been
fighting fires for 27 years I've been a
member of the metis nation of Ontario
since I was 16 years old I gained my
Foundation from indigenous firefighters
who took me out on the line and they
taught me the skills essential to mop up
fires
Jimmy is also a provincial field liaison
officer for the Mexican contingent who
have done multiple deployments this
summer it's quite impressive to see them
go to work with those machetes on the
fire line
it's been explained to me that they
learn from generation to generation the
skills how to use the machete
effectively in the forest
they are using machetes to remove
branches here teams are conducting
planned ignitions which is a key fire
suppression tool it's an emergency
measure so yeah it's planned because
you're going to apply it where you want
to apply it
your objectives in that case you just
want to just nuke the fuel
with climate change fire seasons will
continue to accelerate that's why fire
ecologists like Robert gray say we need
to reimagine how we think about fire
instead of fearing it we need to embrace
it we need to be doing much more
prescribed burning strategically doing
it around communities is a really
important place to be doing it people
they hear us say that and they what do
you mean you're burning next to
communities prescribed burns are similar
to planned ignitions except the goals
are different when managed properly
prescribed fire can be a powerful tool
it can reduce fuel sources create
healthy forests and boost animal habitat
the other thing fire does is it releases
all the nutrients that are stored in the
dead material to explain the benefits
Robert walked us through an area where a
prescribed burn was performed this
spring at the airport in Cranbrook BC so
if you had a little bit of wind and you
drop the match here right now it would
carry a fire even though we burned this
in April it would be really easy to put
out and it wouldn't hurt anything
because it's just such low flame length
so when this ecosystem where grass
dominates that treatment buys you six
months where it might stop a fire but
that's this ecosystem some ecosystems
where it's not grass dominated you do
that prescribed burn and it might buy
you a couple decades
this approach to fire mitigation experts
say should be significantly expanded
especially since these Burns can act
like fences to fire movement if you have
a lot of fences on the landscape and if
you're just slowing down fires it buys
time for the weather to change it buys
time for suppression resources to get
there and eventually you'll start to see
fire size shrink and that's basically
emulating that historic landscape
because the historic landscape was full
of these fences and most of them were
created by indigenous people using
cultural fire
[Music]
this is one area out here that we'll be
hoping to burn this year
on the outskirts of Rocky Mountain House
Alberta Amy Cardinal Christensen takes
stock of her land the research
scientists with the Canadian forest
service is evaluating areas to carry out
cultural burnings so my family's nation
was co-signers on treaty six and right
here we're located in treaty six
territory and so for me it's been a
really cool experience to be able to
bring fire back to this landscape we try
to burn every spring or fall just
depending on the conditions cultural
burning is an indigenous practice using
controlled fire it holds different
meanings for different communities for
cultural fire it's much more of an
activity that's based on a long-term
relationship with the land and one of
the things is trying to put on the
ground these fires that we can walk
beside you know fires that are lower
risk that we can kind of control when
and where they move and that we achieve
certain cultural objectives from Amy
took us to a spot on her property where
she did a cultural fire this spring we
want to maintain this being like an open
grassy meadow area to promote like the
different types of plants here we've got
some amazing raspberries some beautiful
current bushes and a lot of deer that
come to this area so we want to keep it
open there are multiple advantages to
the practice one of which is land
stewardship which can also protect
people indigenous communities are often
the hardest hit by wildfires the
indigenous communities have been
impacted by 42 percent of wildfire
evacuation events so it's a huge
disproportional impact on our
communities compared to other Canadians
Amy's research found that between 1980
and 2021 some indigenous communities
were forced to evacuate several times
some up to seven times during that
period and with this summer we're seeing
even more communities that have been
evacuated multiple times even just in a
single season the idea with cultural
fire right is that you want to preserve
these types of trees she says allowing
communities store their cultural burning
practices is a simple solution to reduce
risk but because of historical and
colonial policies and laws there are
barriers on who can do burnings on which
lands there still exists quite a
paternalistic relationship right now in
terms of fire management often Nations
that I work with they want to do their
own fire stewardship on their
territories and but they're just like
they're honestly not allowed there's
still a lot of hurdles a lot of barriers
to it but it's going to be so important
going forward for indigenous communities
to be able to burn the way they
historically did and for the reasons
that they did the hope now is that
governments will listen One Challenge is
the time required to get a prescribed or
cultural burn approved between planning
and official sign-offs it can take years
and even when it happens it's not large
enough in BC we should be burning on the
order of 200 000 hectares a year to get
up on things where we're way behind and
other provinces very very small burn
programs the U.S does about 150 000
prescribed Burns a year across multiple
agencies about 10 million Acres a year
burnt and they're still in the deficit
they need to be doing more so that's the
scale that we need to be at Robert says
Canada should look to the U.S as a guide
one of the things that's really worked
in the U.S are prescriber and
associations or prescribed fire councils
and then there's a National Coalition of
prescribed fire councils and some of
them are Grassroots LED some are
agency-led and that's a great way to do
it we don't need just one person burning
like a million hectares we need a
million people burning one hectare and
it makes the problem become much more
attainable so build local capacity here
to do the fuels work and then when Fire
season comes you've got more resources
and you can put them on fires and then
when Fire season is done they go back to
doing the fuels work and I think a very
natural partner for that is indigenous
Nations right who are already have that
expertise and knowledge in their
territories
back near Kamloops Jimmy and the Mexican
contingent are making their way to the
Eastern side of the Rossmoor Lake
Wildfire even at a distance from the
Raging Flames danger is all around
and immediately they recognize this tree
across the line Squad boss Simone
Bermudez cuts it down
trees falling have always been a pizza
that's right how much of that in this
area right now is is that on your mind
it's no different this year than years
before one of the first conversations we
always have is where are we going who's
going to be there to help us if we need
to how do we get out and what are the
hazards life and safety are always
number one otherwise what's the point
four firefighters have died on duty this
fire season the first was killed by a
falling tree others have been injured
in light of what we heard over the
weekend was the fourth firefighter to
die on on the front line how are you
doing it kind of brings to um
the Forefront the reality of what's
going on there is inherent risk always
we understand that and when something
like this happens like the the death
unfortunately that occurred this year
it's a reminder of where our priorities
should lie not to get Tunnel Vision on
getting something done but everybody
feels it you know our red shirt's a red
shirt
some Crews will continue to work until
the snow falls but improving conditions
on the ground for the future is going to
be a long haul it goes beyond just
trying to put out all the fires it's
going to take multiple Solutions and
everyone is going to have to be involved
even if we can't you know solve this 100
doing nothing means that we lost the
game I'm still hopeful that if we do
things at the right scale that we can
have a very positive outcome and very
positive benefit for future Generations
we have to I have to believe that